good morning Hank it's Tuesday happy
2017 today's video is like Voldemort
soul it comes to you in eight parts one
of which is inconveniently located
inside our protagonist part one my snot
Hank there is so much snot inside of my
body right now so I apologize if I sound
sick it's because I am sick part two
speaking of my health 100 days has begun
my best friend Chris and I are trying to
have a healthy midwife crisis over the
next 100 days we're going to learn a lot
about health and fitness and over at
youtube.com / 100 days you can see me do
this and also this sweet move and also
quite a lot of this mostly that really
doing partner abs always reminds me that
my stomach was made for resting a laptop
upon but my life is changing pretty
dramatically during these 100 days you
can also follow along with us if you're
so inclined and if you're a nerd con
nerd fight area next month in Boston you
can do a live workout with Chris and me
and our trainer Laura par-3 10 year
anniversary Hank 10 years in one day ago
I uploaded my first ever video to
YouTube in honor of that anniversary
here's a terrible old school
vlogbrothers jump cut if I ever find out
I only have one day to live I want it to
be a day full of 2007 vlogbrothers jump
cuts anyway that first video began I'm
not going to be good at this I wasn't
good at it of course and in many ways
I'm still not but I feel so lucky to be
out of 10 years later and I just want to
say thank you to everyone who's been
part of the last decade with us part
four so a while back we asked a Montana
based artist named Claire Emery to make
some limited edition woodblock prints to
celebrate vlogbrothers 10th anniversary
Claire is just an amazing artist and she
created three prints to celebrate a
decade of nerdfighteria each of them is
available for pre-order now at dftba.com
in black and white or hand colored we're
not getting a royalty or anything on
this we just love these prints and want
to celebrate this anniversary so I hope
you like them also Michael Aranda made a
beautiful video about Claire and her
work which you can watch over at Hanks
channel linked in the doobly-doo
part 5 speaking of celebrating
throughout 2017 Hank and I are going
back to watch every single blog
brother's video for a new project called
this date in vlogbrothers history for
instance on January 3rd 2007 Hank
referenced for the first time that
people were saying we looked like the
Proclaimers and on January 3rd 2011 I
made one of my most viewed videos ever
which I'm sure had nothing to do with
the thumbnail you can watch the videos
and read our reflections on them over at
the community
at youtube.com slash blog brothers slash
community or you can get notifications
by making sure you're subscribed there
is a little button directly beneath the
video and then clicking the bell to get
notifications on fart 6 Hank as you may
have heard nerdfighteria sponsors a
third tier English soccer team called
AFC Wimbledon and this Saturday at 10
a.m. Eastern Time here in the US AFC
Wimbledon will play in the third round
of the FA Cup against Sutton United a
game that will be televised on proper
American cable television specifically
the channel Fox Sports 1 Wimbledon
players wear dftba on the back of their
shorts and you can see those shorts live
in high-definition this Saturday a group
of Colorado nerdfighters will be
watching the game at the Three Lions pub
in Denver and there may also be other
places to watch the game live with
fellow nerdfighters I've started a
reddit thread on the topic linked in the
doobly-doo heart seven punishment tank
in your final video of 2016 you went
over four minutes in a non educational
video which means for the first time in
several years we've got a vlogbrothers
punishment coming your punishment will
take place live on stage at nerdcon
nerdfighteria I'm pretty excited about
this nerdfighters if you have
suggestions for Hanks punishment please
leave them in comments part 8 a moment
of sentimentality
Hank getting to make stuff with you in
nerdfighteria over the last 10 years and
three days has been the great
professional privilege of my life when
we started this project we weren't
particularly close like I left for
boarding school when you were 11 so I
never really knew you as anything other
than a kid
I mean before vlogbrothers we talked on
the phone maybe once a year now it's at
least twice a week these past 10 years
nerdfighteria and its projects have
brought so much joy and fulfillment to
my life but the best of it for me has
been getting closer to you and being
part of the awesome that you bring into
the world Thank You Hank I'll see you on
Friday